all right
welcome everybody to this meeting of
mid-suffolk District Council cabinet
I'm councilor Susie Morley leader of
mid-suffolk District Council and I'm
chairing this meeting today
may I remind you of some domestic
Arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you're attending the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off and that includes
your laptops so they stop beeping when
you get messages
and finally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov app
so please could members make sure they
are logged in and ready to use the app
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
I'm now going to move to the agenda
and I'm going to invite our interim
monitoring officer ft Ali to speak
regarding item 9 which is MCA slash 22
26.
thank you
thank you thank you chair
um our item nine on page 43 there is uh
the appendices that were attached to
that are incorrect how
the appendices were to do with the same
seal report but for uh baber District
Council not for mid-suffolk and we've
corrected that now
cabinet are fully aware of the change
that everyone's cabinet has seen the the
new appendices it's not new in fact
they've it's part of an ongoing program
so I'm quite quite content to continue
with it but if there's anyone here who
hasn't seen the
uh appendices could they speak now and
we'll get a a 100
so we've got some copies here
but they are in mod golf
they're on there yeah they're on this
they're on the system
yes yes
thank you
thank you chair I just want to say to
members that they may have to refresh
their agenda on modern.gov to get the
new appendices
the agenda was updated this morning
thank you chair
um apologies for absences has been
received from councilor Gould and I'm
councilor Brewster
thank you item two to receive
Declarations of pecuniary other
registerable or non-registerable
interests by members are there any to
declare councilor Richardson
thank you chair yes I have to declare a
other registerable interest for agenda
item 10 that's paper MCA slash 22-27 uh
in so far as I have a council Council
appointed director of mid-suffic growth
limited um after receiving advice from
the monitoring officer I'm advised that
the dispensation given to councils is
extended to this meeting so I intend to
debate and participate in the vote as
normal but I'd be grateful if the
interim monitoring of
that's confirmed yes
thank you very much
item three MCA slash 22-14 is confirm
the minutes of the meeting held on the
3rd of October 2022 are there any points
regarding the accuracy of the minutes
councilor Richardson
thank you chair I just
just I know amendments needed in terms
of some of the cabinets portfolios so
paragraph
46.3 should read Council gold Cabinet
member for assets and investment and
paragraph
48.3 referring to myself uh to be
Council Cabinet member for economic
growth but otherwise aside from those
I'll have to propose those minutes
picture
can I have a second to please councilor
flatman
thank you governance officer will now
conduct the vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
foreign
that's seven votes four that's unanimous
thank you very much item four is to
receive notifications of petitions in
accordance with the council's particular
petition scheme none received item five
questions by councilors none received
an item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or the joint audit
and standards committees there are no
matters referred chair
item seven the forthcoming decisions
list are there any comments on that
no thank you item eight
is MCA slash 22 25.
and this is the tenant engagement
strategy
I invite the cabinet member for housing
to introduce this report thank you
Council for adding it thank you very
much
I'm very pleased to introduce this
report MCA slash 22-25 which outlines
our proposed approach to tenant
engagement within housing how we plan to
develop our tenant engagement
opportunities and priorities to enable
efficient and meaningful engagement with
our tenants in the form of our tenant
engagement strategy for 2022 and Beyond
strategy has been developed with our
tenants Insight following our tenant
engagement survey exercise where 1092
tenants responded to the survey which
I'm sure you all agree is a fantastic
response rate and their responses have
provided invaluable Insight which has
informed the developments of this
strategy
the purpose of the strategy is to ensure
our tenants are aware of the available
opportunities to be able to hold us to
account on performance influence the way
we do things and with the center of our
decision-making processes in ways that
suit them
as part of our requirement to comply
with the tenant involvement and
empowerment standard one of the consumer
standards of the regulative social
housing and our ambition to have a truly
tenant-led housing service we feel that
as the strategy we feel that this
strategy underpinned those commitments
and focuses our direction of travel to
ensure we have a good tenant-led
governance structure in place
following the adoption of this strategy
and its Associated delivery plan work
will be undertaken by officers to look
at how we can recruit a representative
range of tenants to a variety of roles
laid out within the strategy in ensuring
we're being both inclusive in terms of
offering engagement and influences and
influence opportunities in both physical
and virtual settings
progress of the delivery plan will be
monitored by the tenant board and
portfolio holders for housing as well as
the strategy itself being reviewed at
least annually the results of which will
be reported to all tenants
I'd therefore like to oppose to propose
recommendations to approve the strategy
as in option one of the report and ask
for a seconder thank you
thank you to have a second
uh yes chair I'm extremely happy to
Second this paper I think it's been very
well written and it just shows that we
take our residents voice very seriously
at mid-suffer thank you thank you
councilor flattman do we have any
questions from cabinet
we have any questions from any other
members present
councilor Weller
um yeah one very brief question am I
allowed to say yeah I welcome the
strategy I think it's well set out so
that that's a good thing Mike but my my
question is around those
those who
those tenants who don't want to engage
but want to complain how I mean we've
all got plenty of them I'm sure that
they'll come they'll come to the member
but they won't go to a tenant board or
or engage in any other way what steps
are you taking to try to engage with
those people and in particular people in
sheltered accommodation
thank you for your question I can answer
at least part of it as you know as you
well know that people often like to get
in touch with their um actual
representatives and and I'm afraid
there's almost you know there's no way
we can sort of stop them from ringing us
oh no and obviously you know you're
always free to to get hold of me and I
can point you in the right direction of
um
you know whose problem it might be um
depending on what the problem is
um
but like I said unfortunately you know
that's always going to happen and I can
point you in the right direction for
that but um as as the sheltered housing
aspect I shall pass that on to David
foreign
in respect to complaints we do have a
housing complaints task force which has
tenant representation on it
um and all of our uh within the strategy
there is a role for um complaint um
Champions as well so we're hoping that
we will be able to learn from the
feedback that we're getting from tenants
and in a way that's their way of
becoming involved with us so it's almost
capturing that silent voice if they if
they don't want to sit on any of the
formal panels or or groups that we might
may set up
and what was the second part of the
question sorry
oh sheltered housing so um we've also uh
we are looking at how we can engage
um more regularly with our sheltered
housing residents
um but similarly we've all across all of
our residents we need to use all
interactions with our tenants as
opportunities for engagement
um so and actually we've got an easier
way of doing that within shelter because
we've got a bit more of a captive
audience with you know a lot of them
having communal facilities Etc
and if I can just add as well that all
all tenants will not not just tenants
but all residents have the ability to
call our customer access point in
to speak to somebody there if they want
to make
comments or complaints or compliments
uh thank you chair
um I'd just like to make a comment and a
question about the response rate
um it's quoted as being 16 in the
document and I just wonder how that
compares with other
um or pre other council's sort of
Engagement and previous tenant
engagement and whether any allowance has
been made in your decision making given
that the 16 who responded are already
engaging and they're saying how they
want to engage in the future but it
still doesn't capture the other 84
percent who aren't engaging at all
um which is a bit of a worry thank you
councilor headingham thank you
um so I'm not
um Dave will know this from their house
marks every I don't know if that's um if
we can if that's something we can um
sorry if we can bring up you know to be
compared with other councils how that's
um the answer the response rate Compares
so I'll pass on to David thank you
uh yeah I don't have the figures right
here and now but I can it is a good
response right just just from kind of my
knowledge of these the types of
exercises that these are
um but I can have a look into that and
figure out what what kind of what the
average kind of response rate is for
those across housing providers it
wouldn't just be local authorities it
would also be housing associations Etc
and in terms of capturing the silent
tenant voice that you're referring to
um there's a lot of work for us as
officers to do in terms of the data that
we hold on our residents and being able
to use that data to ensure that
um you know we know a lot about our
residents and what they want
um or what they might need so using that
data is is how we capture that those
silent voices that don't want to engage
with us
thank you if there's no more questions
I'll open this up for debate does
anybody want to say anything on this
item
s
councilor flattman
um I'd just like to say on behalf of all
the members our residents are you know
we're their first line of contact if
they're worried about something so it's
only natural that they will ring us and
we can we can spawned and pass on
information and help where we can and I
think they think they'll get a quick
response if they ask us and I can assure
you they do
thank you
yes I think it's safe to say that almost
every member regardless of which side of
the chamber you sit on
this is one of our favorite topics of
conversation is is how we look after our
residents and our tenants so it's uh and
this is a fantastic piece of work that's
been done we've been discussing it most
of the summer and it's a really well
written paper and I'm really proud to
um
because he's come forward so thank you
councilor haddington and your entire
team
so
um the option the recommendations is
option one to approve the strategy in
its current form and acknowledge the
changing landscape of social housing
regulations in terms of the significance
of good tenant
ment and I'm now going to ask the
governance officer to conduct the vote
uh sorry members I think I have a
technical glitch uh just one moment
please uh
yeah I have the same problem just one
moment
yes I think we'll take the boat manually
chair if that's okay
okay we're going to take the vote
manually or um cabinet in favor
seven four that's your unanimous chair
so moving on now to item eight this is
MCA slash 22-26 the community
infrastructure Levy expenditure program
for November 2022 I can invite the
cabinet member for planning to introduce
this report councilor burn
thank you
um today we have six syllabids for a
to consider for for the cabinet to
actually decide on uh and two to note
uh and the parishes affected are
Thurston I
old Newton
weatherden and metfield
excuse me
um the first one M21 uh heightened zero
nine is
um for Thurston Community College to
increase uh people places from 1500 to
1650.
this little bit is just over 1.78
million
and is collaborative spend with other
funding coming from section 106 monies
basic need funding and County Council
borrowing giving a total project cost of
just over 2 million
um
just a bit of information about Thurston
College it educates more children than
any other school in Suffolk
and has the largest catchment area
nationally
sixth form is in the top ten ten percent
of sixth form providers in England
this project relates to the second phase
of the expansion of the Thurston
Community College
current capacity of the main thirsting
campus is 1500 places this Expansion
Project will take place in two stages
initially to increase to 1650 places
which is the subject of the still bit
and then to 1800 Place places dependent
on the rate of residential growth
the expansion will provide additional
School places for 11 to 16 year old
pupils and that will be in a new
accommodation consisting of a single
story Standalone block
provide purpose-built teaching and
science spaces
pose will include an additional science
room six class bases a prep room and
toilets
scheme is oven ready which requires
self-funding to be delivered so that the
extension can be opened by 20 September
2023
and Sylvan constitutes essential
infrastructure under the council's
currently current infrastructure
delivery plan and under the education
section within the current
infrastructure funding statement
um
and is recommended to Covenant for
approval
second one is
M22 hyphen zero six which is for I play
facilities at Oak Crescent
uh this syllabid is for a hundred
thousand pounds representing 66 of the
total project costs
Our Town Council are requesting the
sales support to upgrade and develop the
play area on the oak Crescent playing
field the current equipment is outdated
while some has been deemed unsafe and
has had to be closed
the new apparatus will increase the
usage of the site by providing equipment
that can be used for a larger range of
age groups
the project will provide new play
equipment including an in-ground
trampoline zip line different types of
swings for different age groups toddlers
to five plus and multi-play climbing
frame with slide
the project will also resurface the
ground to ensure that the apparatus can
be used all year long
the equipment will use new sustainable
materials to ensure longevity and it
will ensure easier maintenance
with this new apparatus and overall
upgrading for Falling Creek will
increase to the site and this scheme
again is oven ready with all other forms
of funding secured and the cell bid is
regarded as acceptable and it's
therefore recommended to cabinet for
approval
the next M22 hyphen 12
extension to the old Newton Village Hall
this is a silver bid for 67
914 pounds and represents 75 percent of
the total project costs
the old Newton Village Hall and playing
field committee are proposing to extend
the existing Village Hall provision to
enable the Improvement of the current
Village Hall
this part of the phased Works will
provide the village hall with new
storage and bar space along with the
upgrading of current kitchen provision
with the extension to the existing
building the committee are hoping that
this will attract additional bookings
for functions such as weddings and
parties
both Works will also improve the
experience of users of the whole
including the under five playgroup which
use the whole regularly the play group
is currently the principal users of the
building and provides a crucial service
to the local growing community and the
extension will will improve the storage
facilities that they have access to
this amount this amount of civil funding
is regarded as acceptable and is
therefore recommended to cover up for
approval
the final one for
um decision by cabinet today is M22 over
15. this is for the weatherden play area
and the building is for 18
375 pounds and 63 Pence which represents
55 percent of the total project costs
the parish council is requesting cell
support to develop and relocate the new
play area on whether than playing field
the project will provide new equipment
including a four Tower multi-unit a
seesaw a resurfacing of the ground to be
enabled to enable the site to be used
all year round and the parish council
will be providing new operators for
younger children which will increase the
diversity of the equipment and overall
fall to the play area
using sustainable materials will ensure
longevity and the equipment will ensure
easier longevity of the equipment and
will ensure easier maintenance
this scheme is often ready with all
other forms of funding secured and the
silver is therefore regarded as
acceptable
and is recommended to cabin up for
approval
um the ones for just noting are
m2205 I Woodlands footpath
um this is a delegated decision which
has been approved and is for a cabinet
to note only the silver is for five
thousand pounds represent 38 of the
total project costs
um the Imo's Woodland Society are
proposing to improve the user experience
the Imo's wouldn't this has been
achieved with different projects
occurring at the same time
the sill now approved will be assisting
with the construction of a new user
Woodland footpath which runs through the
forest
uh the path will be constructed using
materials which will provide a
additional accessibility to people with
disabilities and users who have
difficulty walking parents with
pushchairs and toddlers
this will increase the overall use of
accessing the Woodland and better the
experience of people using it for
physical activity the approved path will
connect different parts of the foreign
Woodland for example the new picnic area
and the cocoa
that's for nothing
and finally for noting is um M22
hyphen09 which is Improvement to the
Saint John's Meadow play facilities in
metfield
this delegated decision has been
approved and is for cabinet to note the
sill bid is for 8 788 pounds 97 Pence
and represents 75 percent of the total
project costs the metfield parish
council after consultation with local
residents is proposing to upgrade and
provide additional equipment to broaden
the rate the age ranges that the play
play area caters for
the parish council will achieve this by
removing the current aging equipment and
installing new improved operations which
includes a new play Train spring
equipment wavy mirror panels and new
ground surfacing to improve safety
safety and ensure that the site can be
used throughout the year
using new sustainable materials to
ensure the longevity and Equipment will
ensure the easier maintenance
uh
uh the recommendation
uh two cabinets under 3.1 of the report
is to approve these bids and for cabinet
to decide for cabinets and note the
delegated decisions on the bids already
made and also to note and endorse in the
report the still expenditure program at
appendix a and the paragraph 3.2 thank
you very much
I do look for a second to chair if
anybody would like to thank you thank
you councilor flattman yes chair I'm
happy to Second thank you
any questions from cabinet
Council Whitehead
thank you chair
um this is probably a question for
officers I think rather than the cabinet
member but I just wonder what work is
done
um
to establish how much a parish council
can afford to contribute and the reason
I asked that is because
and similar projects and play equipment
weatherden's contributing fifteen
thousand or 33 which is 45 of the
project
I is contributing 550
000 which is three percent so I just uh
perhaps many of the parish councils
watching I think you're doing a project
how you know to try and determine how
much they need to contribute and then
there's some parish councils for example
use the Public Works loans board to
finance say sort of projects so if you
just sort of explain
you know what's like due diligence you
do on the parish councils
no I think that that level of detail is
based answered the binary leaders thank
you
thank you
um we obviously do due diligence that's
not easy to say but uh we do do that
with all cell beds we have debated
whether we should do I think it's not a
terribly good use of term but means
testing where bids come forward from
Parish councils to see what can be
afforded we debated that earlier on in
one of our yearly reviews of the Civil
expenditure framework and quite clearly
I think it's it may be the time now to
take this forward in our next review
which we will be starting probably mid
to end of November because the amount of
neighborhoods sell that we have been
paying out twice yearly has been
increasing uh when bids come in they
come in from communities in a myriad of
forms some of the items that are asked
for are ineligible for cell funding as
you know there is a two thresholds in
place a hundred thousand pound maximum
and there must be they must we mustn't
give more than 75 so we're always
looking for collaborative fund and these
quite a lot does come forward either
from parishes or from neighborhood cell
but I think we probably are at the point
where we could debate that at member
level and decide if we want to take a
different approach
thank you
sort of come back here because it does
feel because it's such a Divergence
between those two
one of them sees a better poker player
than the other vows when it comes to the
money
and we do debate the cell beds with
communities they're all different and so
there's a lot of dialogue about them we
do prompt the use of neighborhood sale
we do look at the disposition some
parishes coming forward have no money or
very little money at all and others have
more but they're actually on their own
program of
delivery of infrastructure projects
using their neighborhood still so
they're trying to get I suppose the the
best contribution from us that they can
get so I think you're right there is a
big Divergence at the moment but we we
will debate that at the next review and
and see what the cross boundary or
cross-party members feel on that and
then bring that forward in the normal
way
animal questions any questions from
anybody else councilor mental
uh thank you I've got a couple of
questions about the Thurston Community
College bid one of which I think is
maybe more directed at the Suffolk
County Council representative that we
have in the room the first question
um is the ring fenced fund which comes
from one two three four five six seven
of our mid-suffolk parishes
um how is that divvied up
regarding each Parish because they're
all vastly different sizes and obviously
contribute more or less pupils to
Thurston Community College
and my second question is clearly
they're still having the largest
catchment area in the country uh vast
tracks of it are in West Suffolk so
we've got a total cost of the project a
as being 2 million
um but is that just the mid-suffic part
of the project because presumably there
will be some section 106 money coming
from West Suffolk because lots of the
pupils from great Barton and the likes
are there they're not ours so I hope
we're not funding them thank you
[Music]
thank you
so I will refer to bulk of that I would
think first of all to to Christine uh to
the professional lead
sir
I don't know which party you wish to
comment on Christine but uh
feel free to cover it all if you want to
or us it's over if you also
also thank you
thank you I think I'll start and then
I'll share with our colleague
um
so in terms of how did we sort out the
ring fencing funds for the Thurston
Community College as members will know
wherever possible we use we use ring
fenced monies first before we use other
monies because we're ring fencing it for
infrastructure which is required for
growth so in this particular case there
are 50 parishes that we counted up that
form the catchment area for this a lot
of them are outside of
um
mid-suffolk so there are only 21
parishes in mid-suffolk and actually
three parishes in Baba the remaining
being in West Suffolk and there is a
contribution from five parishes uh I'm
just gonna see what the figure was
100 and sorry 18
184
595 pounds comes from section 106 monies
and those are all from West Suffolk and
they are captured because of growth that
has taken place so if we we then looked
to our ring fence funnies
ring fenced monies for our 21 parishes
um
in mid-suffolk and there were a total of
five parishes within the catchment area
which contribute to pupil places uh by
that I mean there was growth causing
pressure for people places
and we took a proportionate contribution
from each each of those parishes so the
ones that had much more people places
being derived from growth paid more and
the ones that didn't paid less
out of the remaining parishes there were
only two that had ring fenced funds so
we took uh a much smaller proportion of
contribution there which I think was uh
3753 pounds and five pence on taking
these figures from a technical
assessment
um
and then because this is uh
infrastructure which covers a wide
variety of parishes the remaining
contribution which was just over half a
million came from the Strategic pot so
that is how those
funds have been constructed and how you
see the the silver silk bed being
recommended for approval
I don't know if I've covered
yeah okay
thank you um yeah absolutely as
Christine's uh said we would collect
section 106 contributions from every
development within the catchment area of
Thurston to put towards that
that to phase the expansion if you like
so those developments they may not have
got approval yet in West Suffolk such as
I think there's one in Stanton we've
requested contributions for for an
expansion to Thurston but obviously as
that has not yet been approved we
haven't received those funds yet once
those funds are received we would then
put them towards probably the next phase
of the expansion we send lessons the
impact on the seal funding from mids
Suffolk itself
okay thank you very much
any more questions
no
councilor Whitehead sorry just going
forward on these Parish contributions it
will pass on the reports to show whether
the parish contribution is coming from
still or whether the parish country is
coming from the parish precepts
um I'm sure we can put a little bit more
information in your report uh if that is
what members would like to see in terms
of whether it's coming from neighborhood
still or whether it's coming from a
public works low board or from the
parish precept very happy to do that we
normally ask these questions in any
event
thank you very much
so moving on to debate does anybody wish
to debate this item
okay
so the recommendations are that the
silly expenditure program an
accompanying technical assessments
forming a
silver cabinet to make and approve and
to note
I was follows
m2109
206
to 12
M and
15.
for noting
m2205 and M22 0 9.
so I'm going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the vote thank you
you share that vote is now in progress
thank you chair that is that our seven
votes for and that's unanimous
thank you very much
item 10
MCA slash 22 27 is the Elmer's World
Exemplar housing scheme
um
invite the cabinet member for housing
to introduce this report councilor
adding
I'm very pleased to bring this paper to
cabinet which sets out how an Exemplar
sustainable low-carbon housing scheme
could be delivered in elmswell
earlier in the year this Council
committed to developing housing that is
truly sustainable through the adoption
of the design guide and specification
this guide sets out the standards and
aspirations for new homes that the
council builds while also demonstrating
to others the standards of development
that we expect in mid-suffolk
the land owned by the council for the
specific purpose of providing housing
could be
could be the first low-carbon scheme
demonstrating that we as a council are
committed to delivering
against the aspirations debt out in the
design guide for the benefit of the
district and our residents
these homes would be sustainable by
Design the fabric first approach
providing increased insulation and low
energy designs to enable the properties
to be sustainable to run which is
particularly important in the current
time
the scheme can provide a mix of
properties so much needed social housing
such as affordable rent and affordable
ownership as well as homes to be sold on
the open market
plans would also focus on including
planting to encourage biodiversity
including shared outdoor Community
spaces and a community garden with water
collection and planted buffer zones
between new homes and existing Neighbors
scheme will be delivered by the
council's own development company
mid-suffolk growth limited a venture set
up to enable the council to deliver more
new housing a meaning a meaning higher
standards than profit margins that other
developers would allow
the council will however still look to
achieve a modest return from the sale of
the market homes which can then be
reinvested across the district
thank you do I have a second
councilor Platinum
happy to second
thank you very much do we have any
questions
so why Ted
I have to go first the uh just a
question again is to do with the
under the options options considered an
option 2.2 I'm sorry option two is
called disposal of land and it explains
that HRA owned the land obviously and to
dispose of it on the open market might
be the Secretary of State's approval if
it's being determined as not being
suitable for housing to the use of as
another kind
so I can understand that's like option
two a but there is I think assumingly an
option 2B as well which is to dispose of
it potentially as um to a third party uh
housing
um
Builder
and I assume that would not lead
Secretary of State approval
um to to give a capital sum so is that
right I mean I just think that option
two is perhaps a little uh
um doesn't quite clarify the various
kinds of disposals it just concentrates
on disposal for non-housing purposes
thank you counselor um as this land is
owned by the HRA any disposal of any
purpose would require a secretary of
state approval so whether it's for
alternative purposes or for housing
buyer a third party is my understanding
so the secretary of state has to approve
the disposal to the general fund is that
right
um so the development as proposed would
be undertaken
um with
um jointly with the um
general fund and the HRA and the point
of the HRA is that the funds are then
ring fenced so that those funds can then
be retained within
um the HRA and we'd also be delivering
affordable housing as well as Market
housing so I don't believe Secretary of
State Secretary of State sorry can't
hear a word approval would be required
in that instance
councilor Weller
thank you chair I've got several
questions that I think the the answers
could be quite short so it shouldn't
take too long and there have been some
costs incurred to date in bringing the
scheme to this stage can we be told what
the what level of expenditure has
already been incurred
um do you want me to go through all of
them should we take them one at a time
okay
thank you councilor and the cost to date
have been around about 180 000 pounds
I told you the answer to be sure
the land is owned by mid-suffolk
District Council is the land value
included in the 15 million cost of the
development
because obviously it's part of the cost
of the development the value of it
you know that's only the bill cost for
the development not the land value
just wondered if
I mean it may well be that we can't be
told uh in public what the land value is
so you know if if that's not available
either in public or to anyone else and
perhaps I can be told that outside of
the meeting thank you
um now looking at the cost
um it's it's about around 15 million
pounds which works out at 300 000 pounds
per unit
which seems very high even given the
approach which is quite rightly being
taken
um is there a breakdown of the costs
which show how the 15 million is split
up for instance uh split between
consultants and design fees
separately construction and separately
any other costs because there could well
be some marketing costs for the market
properties
yes councilor that there are those costs
and but we didn't think it was
appropriate to put those costs in an
open paper bearing in mind we will need
to Tender for these Works in due course
so more than happy to share that
breakdown with you outside of this
meeting
that's it thank you very much
thank you um I'm going to invite
councilor Mansell as the ward member for
elmsworld to speak on this item as well
councilmanson uh thank you chair
um I think this is a really exciting
project for Elms well and I and I'm I'm
very pleased that the you know you've
picked Elms well to put this Exemplar
scheme
um and the fact that it's going to be
really sustainable environmentally
sounds but there are some issues with
this particular proposal now we're all
aware that there are a need for
affordable there is a big need for
affordable homes throughout the district
and in elmswell
um and uh the Ellsworth Parish Council
set up a community land trust and they
are working towards providing 12
affordable dwellings on um what was the
old uh behind the Old Tavern on school
roads
um the community land trust is is quite
happy to work with mid-suffolk Growth
Company towards a Cooperative scheme at
the tavern site
and this particular land
um that we're talking about now now that
I was made aware
um last night that the red line area
that you've got in your in your papers
does not all belong to mid-suffolk
um a part of it has been sold off to one
of the nearby residents and I hope that
that is going to be cleared up before we
get any further
um but anyway
um that's beside the point really
because I'm sure that that's a a
technical tweak which can be changed on
a map
um now we we are elmsworth it does
actually have quite a lot of built um
building developments going on
um and there is one proposal which is
currently to go to planning next month I
think for
um some affordables at the old baker
Factory site and there's affordables at
Bali Crescent already being built
um so I would like to just make the
cabinet aware that elmsworld Parish
Council uh put forward a scheme to
provide extra Primary School places uh
within elmsworld itself rather than
having to bus them over to woolpit which
is the current proposal so the current
School announce what is insufficient to
meet all of the committed development in
elmsworld
um so the parish council have put
forward this proposal
um which has involved some formal
meetings
um with the schools planning manager our
friend Mr Mumford who was here earlier
um the county councilor myself and
councilor geek and Planning and Building
control Emily attack and Holly Brett
have been made aware of this initiative
that that the prime the parish council
uh think that it is an ideal site to put
a school
so they um the parish council
um have uh think that 6.25 acre plot uh
were added to a 1.14 acres to the
slightly to the West adjacent to the
Church Road together with 1.5 Acres of
Suffolk County Council land which is
where the old primary school was just to
the north
the aggregated area access from Church
Road would allow for a 420 Place pupil
School in the grounds allowing adequate
formal and informal Recreation
most of what you're saying does not
directly relate to the item on the
agenda yes it does it's about the piece
of land we want to put the school here
instead of you making for housing
pointing we'd Suffolk growth
growth yeah but the planning committee
no I know it's not a planning committee
it's the just that that
um we don't we in ellsworld do not think
that this land should be if you let me
come finish I think we ought to explore
the other options before mid-suffolk
before the cabinet make this decision
right so anyway that we don't have
enough Primary School provision in Elms
well the parish council think that this
particular site um would make a really
good site for a primary school so I
think that um it would be better if we
deferred this decision about what to do
with this land until
um these uh other uh options have been
fully explored by mid-suffolk
s
Emily would you like to comment on any
of that
uh thank you and only to say that
um the next stages of this development
include further engagement with the
local community and so I'm sure we will
address that issue or discuss that issue
further as we move and the proposals
further forward and obviously uh part of
our engagement will be about then
developing up a planning application
which again you know will come through
the uh planning committee system as well
so I think really it's just the point
that we've had initial engagement
um with the with the parish council and
we are expecting to undertake much wider
engagement and consultation
Channel redstone
residents thank you
I'm now going to move to debate does
anybody wish to comment councilor
Richardson
thank you chair um just a couple of
brief comments for me
um I just kind of really wanted to
emphasize that this I think really is a
prime opportunity to deliver affordable
housing in excess of what a private
developer would ordinarily uh
precise of this size and I know
obviously there is a modest Prophet
associated with this scheme but I think
it really is that social and
environmental benefit that is really um
value to the communities is really the
most important part of the scheme so I'm
very happy to support it and we'll be in
vote in favor of it thank you
totally agree this is land that is owned
by our HRA it can only be used for
housing
and this is the best way of delivering
affordable housing for our residents I
also will be supporting this application
and we will keep an eye on the costs
um we're well aware that
um
costs are a bit unpredictable at the
current in the current climate so we
will keep an eye on the costs going
through the Growth Company so I'm now
going to ask the governance officer to
counselor white tent
as part of the debate
um and you know I'd like to say that I
think it's an exciting and commendable
project and it's great that we are come
to an example a scheme
um you know as a council to show what
can be done here just wanted to raise
one or two concerns with my sort of
Finance hat on because I know the paper
was written several weeks ago and things
that things have been changing quite
dramatically in the last few weeks I
mean everybody seems to
blame this trust but I think the reality
is that the economics of you know the
whole country are changing at base rates
have doubled from one and a half percent
to three percent in the last five or six
weeks and off the back of that
um people are forecasting experts are
forecasting quite drastic
um reductions in house prices all be in
the short term I believe this is a
project which could take three years to
come to fruition so perhaps at the far
side of that dip by that time
but I'm just a bit concerned I'm
recommendation 3.4 which is approving
the capital
I just wonder if it's have some sort of
subject to some sort of feedback
mechanism before the final drawdown of
the funds you know sort of approval in
principle but I think we need to see
more costings the tendering process the
planning process and the conditions that
come out of that
um wonder what sort of feedback
mechanism we can have to prove it in
principle but still have some control as
a cabinet
Emily is that possible
and we do report
um through two cabinet briefing and to
the holding companies on a quarterly
basis and from mid-suffolk growth
perspective they do need to have the
funds secured you know in order to move
forward in reality as with all
developments we have gateways so that we
review at each Gateway
um whether you know what the most
appropriate next steps are and so my
recommendation would be for the cabinet
to agree the recommendations that are
set out in the report but will of course
continue to keep a cabinet briefed in
terms of the progress of this project
and should any matters change in in the
way that we would with any project
thank you I'm happy with that
so I'm now going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
thank you members that vote is now in
progress
thank you chair that is seven votes for
and that's unanimous
thank you very much everybody so the
date and time of the next meeting is
scheduled for Monday the 5th of December
at 10 30. uh meetings